for the shadow economic secretary to the
treasury tulip City joins me now in the
studio and and do you support the the
this government plan to strengthen
relations with Australia and the US
we do support the plans obviously
anything that helps our national
security and us on the world stage is
something that we support we would like
to take a bit more of a sophisticated
approach when it comes to China
obviously when it comes to human rights
violation which we've spoken up
constantly on whether it's the uyghurs
or other mistreatment in China I want to
speak out on them but we also feel there
should be some sort of approach of
coordinating with China and speaking to
them in our national interest and by
that I mean last in the last integrated
review not this one they described China
the government itself described China as
a strategic partner and that's something
we want to focus on we still have to
work with China especially on things
like climate change China is the world's
largest emitter of carbon dioxide when
we looked at that we're not going to get
into a situation where we tackle climate
change without working with China so I
feel personally that we have to take a
more sophisticated approach so in terms
of strengthening language against China
calling China a threat you're saying
that that is not something the labor
party would be doing you'd be more
talking with them I think we have to
engage with them in our national
interests and you know I want to be
absolutely clear when it comes to human
rights violation as I've just said when
it comes to the uyghur which we've
spoken out called it a genocide those
things of course we need to call it out
but there's no doubts about the fact
when it comes to China such as I said
climate change such as trading such as
the fact that there's a huge number of
Chinese students who come to this
country and study here and contribute an
enormous contribution we just want to
make sure that we're dealing with them
in a situation where we can still talk
to them and work with them when it comes
to our national interests okay a large
part of why we're talking about this
pact is because of the money that it's
costing Rishi next pledge to increase
defense spending by 5 billion over the
next two years does the labor party
think that's enough we do support them
we do think it's come a bit too late
we've been asking for this review for
nearly a year now and we feel that
money's finally here we are happy to see
that the money's here but we would have
liked it a lot earlier and what about
the actual sum would you like more money
I mean we always want more money for
defenses about where um you know we make
constant other places but there's no
doubts about the fact that we've been
asking to beef up our defense spending
for a long time one of the things I
would like to point out though I want to
see how the government actually delivers
on everything that they've put in the
review in terms of capabilities because
apparently they haven't managed to
fulfill everything that they promised
last time so it's about a delivery plan
as well as pledging the money as well
and we haven't seen that in action and
in terms of pledges from labor your
party says the government you don't have
a particular plan or a timetable for
lifting the defense spending you you've
pledged to live from 2.1 percent to 2.5
percent
why are you not putting a timetable on
that because for a start like everyone
else we don't know when the next
election is going to be I mean I don't
know if you know but we certainly don't
know but also we don't know from six
months on from the next election but
when is the next election and what kind
of economy are we going to inherit I
mean one of the reasons I know it's
frustrating for people when they say can
you put a timeline can you put an exact
date if we knew when the election was
going to be if we knew what kind of
economy we were going to inherit what
the inflation rates are going to be what
the books will look like once we take
control if we do manage to win the next
election and we've got to make decisions
based on that I'm very reluctant to be
drawn into it because I feel that we can
make all these promises but once we're
there things might be very different but
then what's the point of making the
promises because they're not with a hill
of beans if you're going to say right
well we're going to spend 2.5 on defense
but you know realistically it could be
10 years down the line it's not it's not
something that we're going to be doing
in the first six months of a labor
government or the first two years of a
labor government
that there's no point in in any of these
promises is there well it's signaling
our intent it's signaling what our
priorities are and what we want to
prioritize when we get into government
but also the things that we are deeply
thinking about right now it's just hard
to put timelines on it but it's still an
indication of what we think is important
if we are governing the country where
would labor find the money to increase
the defense budget from well apparently
there was a huge amount of waste from
the government when it came to defense
spending anyways that's one thing to
look at is how much money they wasted
and we would use that but like I said we
haven't yet well no it would be the
money that's been wasted so that's one
of the things we would look at but in
all honesty the money has got to be
decided once we know what we inherit
from the economy and I think we would
have to obviously look at other
um parts of the economy decide what we
want to cut and we haven't got into
those details so it's very difficult to
outline exactly but we feel it's a
priority I do think whether we put a
timeline on on it or not to Signal our
intent to say this is what's important
to us is what the electorate want to
hear and I think that's what my
constituents want to hear we've got the
budget tomorrow of course a few things
have been trailed and one of them today
is about pensions about increasing the
lifetime amount you can put in your
pensions now of course this does just
affect people who've got an awful lot of
money because we're talking about people
with a million pounds in pension savings
um do you think this is the right thing
for the government to be doing
we in the labor party support older
people as we always have done we support
pensioners I think the talk about
pensions at the moment is pure
speculation that I don't think we've got
any details I don't know if you've
received any details I was listening
this morning and it sounded like it was
speculation I think I'd have to see the
details before I comment but it's about
the pension cap and it's about at the
moment the pension cap is about a
million just over a million pounds that
you can put in over your whole life
it could be going up to about a million
and a half so it's it's essentially
encouraging people to put away more for
a rainy day if they of course have any
spare money to put away I mean is that
something that a party would support
have you had that confirmed the details
because I heard a conservative MP say
those details weren't confirmed but have
you heard it confirmed but it's more
than a principle yeah do you think in a
budget that we should be encouraging
people to save more and facilitating
that those kind of savings I think I I
represent a constituency where people
are saying that if they had an
unexpected 500 pounds come their way
they wouldn't be able to pay it because
things are so bad for them so of course
we always want people to save more I
would like to see the details though
because is there a catch in it and
somehow are older people and more
vulnerable people going to pay the
penalty that's what I'd like to know
before I fully commit but if you're
asking me should people have some
savings and should we be encouraging
people to save well of course I mean you
know people are in a situation where
anything that throws them off normal
life and the finances that they have to
pay they struggle to pay it so
yeah what would your priorities be for
tomorrow's budget well we've talked
about how we want a proper windfall tax
I'm sure you've heard this before the
government's bought one in but we've
talked about how we would like to
bagdated and we'd like to close a
loophole which allows investment fossil
fuel we don't we want to close that
loophole we want to raise more from the
windfall tax but the other thing we've
talked about if there is Headroom we'd
like to freeze field Duty and that's
what we've said to the government it
sounds like from people who are
commenting on the budget that they will
be headroomed to do this if there is an
opportunity we think that would be very
beneficial for the country to freeze
field Duty we're also seeing a fresh
wave of strikes this week we've got
Junior doctors out on strike they're
wanting a pay rise of over 30 percent
how realistic is it do you think that
they should get that I was with a junior
doctor yesterday because Kia storm are
hosted an international women's day
event with women from the health sector
and I spoke to a junior doctor the first
thing I'd say is that no one goes on
strike on a whim they're striking
because they genuinely feel that their
conditions are terrible they haven't
received right pay for us the solution
is very clear we would sit around the
table we would speak to them and there'd
be some sort of negotiation the truth is
no one's got a message that the baby
party conveyed to the junior doctors
because we had one on the sofa yesterday
and they've admitted that they've had a
letter from the health Minister inviting
them for talks they're not going to go
for those talks well I think if we could
have a proper conversation in which we
discuss
some sort of negotiation look no one's
ever going to be completely happy and
that's the result of a negotiation you
talk yet something's got to give but
right now I feel we're in a situation
where my children aren't going to school
two days this week and we went to a e
quite recently with a family member we
were there for hours we're in a
situation we've got to talk to people
who are providing these essential Public
Services I think the government's done a
very bad job of it tulips Shadow
economic secretary's treasury thank you